herr schmidt chanasit wenn wir an die
hotspots denken wir uns bislang so
geläufig waren
das war heinsberg die karnevalsfeier ist
das sind hot spots die drinnen
stattgefunden haben wenn sie jetzt diese
bilder sehen würden sie sagen diese
demonstrationen von freunden oder auch
die partys die draußen stattfinden die
sind gar nicht so schlimm oder sind dass
möglicherweise doch super spreading
events na gut das ist jetzt spekulativ
wir müssen aber die bilder nochmal
deutlich unterscheiden das was in berlin
passiert ist mit diesem schlauchbooten
die einander vorbei gefahren
das was jetzt am goldstrand in bulgarien
passiert das sind ja auch sozusagen
unterschiedliche settings in einem
unterschiedlichen infektionsgeschehen
ist es ganz wichtig dass unterscheiden
wir haben trotz alledem sehr sehr
geringe infektionszahlen in deutschland
in bulgarien sieht er zum beispiel
anders aus und insofern muss man das
bewerten und was jakobikirche meyer
gesagt hat ich kann natürlich nur
unterstreichen was man dort auch
wahrnimmt diese zunehmende spaltung zum
einen alt und jungen oder arm und reich
oder stadt und land ich nehme das auch
verstärkt war und das ist ein problem
mit dem man umgehen muss man kann sagen
ja das ist alles schlimm das gehört
alles verboten aber ich glaube das hilft
das wird uns nicht weiterbringen den
nächsten monaten oder jahren man muss
lösung finden um mit diesem jahr
vielleicht auch wünschen der der jungen
menschen umzugehen und ich denke wir
haben technische möglichkeiten das in
deutschland umzusetzen um eben auch zum
teil so etwas zuzulassen natürlich immer
unter kontrolle es geht ja nicht
irgendwie darum die tore zu öffnen alles
so wie früher zu haben nein aber mit
technischen möglichkeiten kann man
sicherlich hier auch zu einem stück
normalität zurückkehren und dann findet
das ähnlichem bulgarien statt sondern
eben kontrolliert bei uns und dann haben
wir auch einen überblick und können
eingreifen wenn es eben problematisch
werden sollte